bienvenue dans reporter sur france 24
nouvel épisode aujourd'hui de notre
série sur les frontières du monde ces
points chauds de la géopolitique
direction le laos petit pays enclavé le
sol en asie du sud-est à ne pas avoir
d'accès à la mer inauguré il ya quelques
mois une ligne de chemin de fer est en
train de tout changer elle permet
désormais de franchir facilement la
frontière et de se rendre sans encombre
dans le pays voisin la chine une
révolution qui ouvre bien des
perspectives commerciales des deux côtés
de la frontière c'est un reportage de
adrie berger aidara pas thammavong avec
séverine bardon et olivier mars
[Musique]
décembre 2021 dans la gare flambant neuf
devient cian le laos inaugure sa
première grande ligne de train
ce jour est très important dans
l'histoire du laos qui est très nouveau
moyen de transport moderne permettra de
développer encore plus notre pays c'est
un rêve devenu réalité
par écran interposé à cause de la
pandémie de co vide le président du laos
s'adresse à son homologue chinois et à
cette occasion je voudrais exprimer ma
gratitude envers le président en chine
ping et le gouvernement chinois pour
leur aide inestimable
les 420 km de lignes à grande vitesse
ont été construits et financés à 70 %
par la chine dans le cadre des nouvelles
routes de la soie les passagers du
trajet inaugural de la voie ferrée entre
le laos et la chine sont invités à
monter à bord attention au départ
depuis 20 ans yann le train permet de
rallier la frontière en trois heures à
peine de là la voie ferrée se connecte
au réseau chinois pour le laos seul pays
d'asie du sud-est sans accès à la mer
c'est la promesse d'en désenclavement et
d'un nouvel essor économique et il est
un endroit où cette promesse a déjà un
goût de réalité boten la ville
frontalière côté la hausse
je suis venu récupérer une voiture qui
arrive de chine pour l'instant elle est
dans un entrepôt ici à beauté je vais la
vérifier la ramener à vinciane
button s'est beaucoup développée et les
entreprises de logistique se porte
vraiment bien ici
à
sur la frontière entre la chine et le
laos la zone économique spéciale de
boston sort de terre
[Musique]
ce projet de 10 milliards de dollars
entièrement développé par une entreprise
chinoise sur le sol laotien a débuté en
en 2035 la ville nouvelle devrait
accueillir 300 mille habitants
[Musique]
c'est très confortable à porter parfait
pour le nouvel an laotien
neu est originaire de vientiane la
capitale du laos elle s'est installée à
boston avec ses enfants pour se
rapprocher de son mari chinois et
profiter des opportunités commerciales
de la ville frontalière
ce produit intéresse beaucoup en ce
moment
depuis trois ans elle gère ce petit
bazar de quartier qui proposent des
produits à bas coûts
ces chaussures viennent de chine
celles ci viennent du vietnam la plupart
des chaussures viennent de ces deux pays
vêtements cosmétiques babioles du
quotidien dans le magasin de noël la
majorité des produits sont importés et
les prix sont plus souvent donné en yuan
chinois quand type laotien une façon de
s'adapter à la clientèle locale
la plupart des gens qui habitent beauté
ne sont pas originaires d'ici
ils viennent d'autres provinces et de
chiens
ils sont venus s'installer juste après
la construction de la vie ils ont loué
des maisons et des emplacements
commerciaux
boston a une histoire singulière dans
les années 2000 le petit village endormi
des confins du laos s'était transformée
en ville casino prisé des chinois
mais en 2011 le gouvernement de pékin a
imposé la fermeture de tous les
établissements de jeux et bolton est
retombé dans la torpeur
jusqu'à sa renaissance en zone
économique spéciale
ici en 2015 2016 il n'y avait rien
juste des chants et une petite place
maintenant il y a des immeubles partout
[Musique]
la ville accueille désormais deux mille
habitants dont 80 % de chinois
[Musique]
steven joe louis est un précurseur il
s'est installé très tôt a bottle dont il
a vu l'évolution spectaculaire au fil
des ans
dans l' usine qui l'a ouverte ici il y à
7 ans déjà près de la moitié des
employés sont chinois
et celui là tu ne l'as pas encore rempli
c'est ça non il faut encore attendre 20
minutes pour cet entrepreneur chinois le
choix de bottle est le résultat d'un
calcul mûrement réfléchie et en pari sur
l'avenir
[Musique]
en 2005 j'ai construit une usine garonne
pour tabac au zimbabwe
et puis en 2015 la chine a lancé les
routes de la soie et je me suis dit que
le laos pourrait être une belle
opportunité pour moi
alors j'ai transféré mon usine de
l'afrique au laos
j'ai choisi button parce que la plupart
de mes clients sont en chine et que
boston est une zone économique spéciale
à la frontière du laos et de la chine
en plus il y a un programme des de
développement industriel
a bottle la création d'entreprise et
faciliter les procédures administratives
sont bouclés en deux semaines de
nombreux produits sont détaxés la
fiscalité est avantageuse en trois ans
une centaine d'entreprises s'est
implanté dans cette ville toujours en
construction pesic ovide le
développement de bolton a ralenti mais
je suis convaincu choquée dès que la
pandémie sera terminée
automne se développera à nouveau très
vite
il y aura un boom économique de cette
ville
syngenta
[Musique]
les stricte politique de confinement ton
côté laotien que chinois ont durement
touché bottone la plupart des chinois de
la ville ont regagné leur terre natale
avant la fermeture de la frontière
[Musique]
oh mercy one c'est super pour
transporter la bière on ne saura que
toutes les deux
non elle n'a jamais envisagé de quitter
boten même ralentie par la pandémie la
ville lui offre des opportunités qu'elle
ne trouverez nulle part ailleurs au laos
je fais quelques livraisons ont fait ça
à peu près tous les jours ce n'est pas
beaucoup mais c'est déjà ça
c'est à cause de la situation économique
en ce moment hier on a livré un peu de
bière quelques caisses seulement elle
n'est ici que depuis trois ans pourtant
la jeune femme a déjà ouvert un deuxième
commerce de vente et livraison en gros
de boissons ah mais c'est trop lourd tu
n'en prend qu'une comme ça elle emploie
aujourd'hui cinq personnes et ne compte
pas s'arrêter là
si les frontières rouvre j'aurai
davantage de travail
je pourrais aussi livré et vendre des
vêtements
j'aurais tellement de travail
que je ne pourrais pas de tout faire
tout seul et j'aurai besoin d'embaucher
même si les deux communautés se
mélangent peu chinoise et laotien de
bottone partage le même optimisme
seuls leurs moyens et leur rêve d'y
faire sinon bonjour chef ça fait
longtemps comment vas-tu bienvenus
asseyez-vous
dans un salon de thé flambant neuf
stephen jones retrouve un compatriote
l'occasion pour les deux hommes de
parler business et perspectives d'avenir
[Musique]
ni d'as comment vont les affaires cette
année
on a lancé la production avant-hier ce
sera après le mois prochain les
commandes étaient un peu plus important
que l'an dernier mais cette année il y a
clairement l'influencent du coc vide
situe un business plan de long terme le
coc vide ce n'est pas si grave
en fait si tu as des objectifs de long
terme
c'est même plutôt une bonne chose
ça élimine les entreprises les moins
compétitives
par exemple acheté cet hôtel
si on était en temps normal
combien savoure écouter oui c'est vrai
malgré ou peut-être grâce aux qu'ovide
monsieur sion vient d'acheter un hôtel
et plusieurs autres bâtiments il prévoit
d'ouvrir une école internationale
trilingue en pariant sur la situation
géographique de boston
alors globalement
tué optimiste sur l'avenir de beauté
dans le cadre des routes de la soie la
chine a investi des centaines de
milliards en asie du sud-est et surtout
à la hausse avec la voie ferrée
l'autoroute mots l'avenir les
investissements de la chine en asie du
sud est ils seront forcément centré sur
le laos
au laos et ailleurs de nombreuses voix
s'élèvent pour dénoncer la dépendance du
pays envers la chine la mainmise de l'
empire du milieu sur son petit voisin
loin de ces considérations politiques
les pionniers de boston comme neu et sa
soeur qui vient de la rejoindre espère
juste qu'il se construire un avenir
meilleur
moi botan mon rêve serait d'acheter une
voiture et un beau terrain ça ne prendra
pas longtemps qui verra moi quand je
suis arrivé ici je n'avais rien mais
maintenant j'ai une voiture une maison
un terrain et je peux subvenir aux
besoins de mes enfants il faut juste un
peu de temps et de patience
quand on vivait à 20e on n'avait rien
non plus et quand j'ai vu le succès que
tu avais ici j'ai décidé de venir aussi
tu crois que je réussirai aussi bien que
toi bien sûr tu y arrivera
grâce au tram et aux nouvelles
autoroutes récemment inauguré entre la
chine et le laos boston s'est transformé
en noeud de communication quand la
frontière se mue en trait d'union elle
devient aussi parfois une terre
d'opportunités
[Musique]
et voilà donc pour cette découverte de
la frontière entre le laos et la chine
et ces nouvelles opportunités
commerciales
c'est la fin de ce magazine merci à vous
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur france 24
[Musique]